welcome to your mom's house
can I talk about the dump I talk just
warning though oh that would be great I
feel like I didn't I haven't talked to
you about this yet today we've been so
busy but you know when you go to shit
and you're like this is just gonna be a
run-of-the-mill dump and then you look
in the bowl and you're like that's like
a footlong yeah that's what happened
well that's neat yeah yeah but it didn't
feel that long coming out and it didn't
feel like it would be that nice mhm no
how many shits have you taken today one
really one and it's 115 Wow some kind of
right so much for mister I've got a
problem
Oh too much you do this thing that's so
unfair no matter and when I'm taking a
shit you go do you ever and are you ever
not shitting no it's cuz you always
choose to take a shit when we're doing
something together as a family like oh
we're putting our son to sleep I got a
shit or we're having a nice moment with
people I should shoot as an excuse to
get away from I'm not using it I have to
go now okay